بعد حفله اتهامات شيرين تصدم الجمهور
بالعوده الى حسام ونور الرياض يطلقوا
مزادا خيريا لاعمال اربعه فنانين اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا
شيرين عبد الوهاب اللي ما غاب اسمها عن
الاخبار ومصدره العناوين منذ شهور ما زالت
ضمن العناوين الرئيسيه واسمها تريند على
المنصه من امس وذلك بسبب مفاجاه غير
متوقعه فجرتها شيرين مسلسل شيرين وحسام
حبيب تعددت حلقاته وتنوعت عناوين تلك
الحلقات من الحب والزواج لاتهامات والطلاق
وانتهاء ايضا بالمخدرات والامراض النفسيه
والمستشفيات هذا طبعا غير شائعات الكثيره
الفنانه شيرين اللي عانت خلال الفتره
الماضيه من ظروف صحيه او عفوا ظروف شخصيه
وحتى صحيه ايضا صعبه ظهرت للعلم ودخلت على
اثرها المستشفى للعلاج لفتره قبل خروجها
من ايام وكانت المفاجاه باعلانها للناس
عبر برنامج الحكايه مع الاعلاميه عمرو
اديب دعونا نتابعه
وانا حابب ان الخبر ده يتقال عندنا هنا في
البرنامج عشان نفرح معاك كل الناس ايه
الخبر السعيد اللي عندك النهارده
[موسيقى]
بمشيئه رب العالمين كتب كتابي على السيد
حسام
تحياتي لقوم يتفكرون
والنبي صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه من
قال اذا جاءكم من ترضون خلقا ودينه فزوجوه
لم تفعلوا تكل فتنه في الارض وفساد كبير
وان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بين انه من
امان البيوت انه لابد وان يتلى فيها كتاب
الله عز وجل وان يذكر فيها
الذكر الحكيم لقول الله عز وجل ومن يعشق
عن ذكره الرحمن القيد له شيطان وهو له
قريب وقال النبي الامين صلى الله عليه
وسلم
مثل البنت الذي ذكر فيه الماء والبيت الذي
لا يذكر الحي والميت ودائما يعني نحسن
انفسنا بافكار كان يقوله النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم في كل صباحه والمساء زي مثلا لا
اله الا الله
التامه من كل شيطاننا ومن كل عين لما بقول
النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام اعوذ بكلمات
الله التامات من شر ما خلق فهذا يعني امان
للبيوت ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجمع
بينكم في الخير
يعني مثل ما سمعتوا وشاهدته مشاهدينا
الفنانه شيرين بنفسها اعلنت عودتها لزوجها
حسام حبيب وبهذا الاعلان تنتهي بكل
الشائعات اللي لاحقه الثنائي خلال الفتره
الماضيه شيرين اكدت خلال المكالمه
الهاتفيه في برنامج الحكايه على انها
تتمتع بصحه جيده الان وامورها الصحيه في
تحسن واضافت ايضا انها سامحت اخوها محمد
اللي كان السبب في ادخالها المستشفى
للعلاج وتم تداول ايضا معلومات انه ضربها
ووجهت رساله لمحبيها ولا حسام حبيب كمان
هتنازل عن اي حاجه انا كنت عاملها
لمحمد سعيد عبد الوهاب
بينك وبين اخوك خلاص هتشيليها طبعا لان
انا ما اقدرش اعمل كده انا انا انا شيرين
اللي قلبها متسامح وهيفضل متسامح بعتذر
لحسام عن كلام قدر مني في يوم من الايام
فانا عايزه اطمئنهم علي واقول لهم ان هنا
في عصره راجل طيب جدا
وحبيب من البدايه ولو كنت طلعت في يوم من
الايام قلت كلام عنه همم كان هو ما زعلني
منه او كلام بيده الشيطان بيحصل بين اي
اثنين متجوزين واحنا كان معمول لنا حاجه
كبيره قوي قوي
واحنا كنا ضحيه حاجه كبيره قوي قوي والحمد
لله ربنا فكها بسلام
عموما من بدايه قصه شيرين وحسام كثير من
الناس متابعين تطورات ومتعطفين بشكل او
باخر مع شريف من بينهم طبعا فنانين اظهروا
ادعمهم لشيرين خلال وجودها في المستشفى
لكن اللي صار انه من بعد ما اعلنت 20 خبر
عودتها لحسام اتفضل هاشتاج اين الكرامه يا
شيرين تصدر المنصات وجمهورها وعدد من
الفنانين اعتبروا عودتها هو النوع من
التعلق واهدار للكرامه وخاصه انه 20 سابقا
كانت قالت انها بحاجه الى معجزه للعوده لا
حسام حبيب
معنى الان من القاهره الناقد الفني طارق
الشناوي اهلا بك استاذ طارق معنا في
تفاعلكم يعني على ما يبدا استاذ طارق
المعجزه اللي كانت تتحدث عنها شيرين بانها
لن تعود الى حسام حبيب فقط
استاذ طارق سامعني
استاذ طارق انا سمعتك انت سامعني
راح نحاول نصلح مشكله الصوت لحتى يسمعنا
استاذ طارق وبنرجع له بعد قليل
اهلا بكم من جديد
طارق الشناوي هناك اهلا فيك استاذ طارق هل
تسمعني الان
اهلا اهلا
طيب اذا المعجزه اللي كانت تتحدث عنها
الفنانه شيرين بانها لن تعود الى او
محتاجه لمعجزه لحتى تعود لحسام حبيب
المعجزه بالفعل تحققت وعادت الان باعتقد
بانه كثير من ااا متابعين ومحبين الفنانه
شيرين بطلوا فاهمين اي حاجه
ايه اللي بيحصل
لا انا انا انا فاهم طبعا هي في حاله
نفسيه واضح يعني مش هتعرف تكون طبيب نفسي
او متخصص في الطب النفسي انك انت تعرف انت
امام شخصيه
ثنائيه القطب يعني يعني دائما تتنقل من
اقصى اليمين لاقصى اليسار من اقصر رفض
لاقصر الموافقه من من اسوا الالفاظ
والصفات اللي بتلعب بها طليقها الى اعظم
الصفات طارق
اه هي شخصيه فعلا
ثنائيه القطب يعني رايحه يعني حبه فوق
وحبه تحت مش مش وبعدين هي كانت في
المستشفى لمده 20 يوم ومستشفى المفروض
المده دي كلها وخروجها لا يعني نهايه همم
التعافي لا ممكن بدايه التعافي لكن لا
يعني التعافي المطلق
وعشان كده القرارات اللي بتتخذها برده
قرارات متطرفه يعني ازاي لسه خارجه بقى من
يومين وبعد كده بعد ساعات يعقد قرارنا على
من اتهمته على الملا امام الراي العام كله
بصفات صعب ان الواحد يعيدها مره اخرى على
مسمع ومراه من الجمهور في حاجه مش طبيعيه
وما بني على باطل فهو باطل يعني يعني قرار
الزواج نفسه مبني على شخصيه غير قادره على
اتخاذ قرار صائب في اللحظه دي طب وغير
مستعد على الاطلاق
الشخصيه وهي حره تتزوج او همم تطلق من
تريد يعني وتعود لمن تريد بس هي الفكره
لما يكون فيه
ما هذا هذا اللي انا جاي له في الحديث
احنا كم كم محبين او جمهور الفنانه شيرين
هو نوعا ما طرف في الموضوع على الاقل او
طرف همم يعني همم
همم استثمر عاطفيا بهذه القصه من واقع حبه
للفنانه شيرين لما بيكون فيه لغط بحياه
همم فنان الشخصيه لهذه الدرجه وهذا اللغط
يكون على الملا وعلى العالم وعلى السوشيال
ميديا كيف بياثر على جماهيريته وحب الناس
لا له وثقتهم فيه ايضا
طبعا هي وراثه الناس في معركه خاصه زي ما
حضرتك قلتي دي حاله خاصه جدا بتحصل بين
ازواج طلاق وحب وزواج وخيانه وغيرها
وغيرها عادي دي الحياه كذا هي الحياه لكن
هي صداره كل ده للراي العام فبالتالي من
حق الراي العام ايضا ان يكون لها وجهه نظر
سلبيه في الشخصيه طبعا هناك صوره ذهنيه
سلبيه متعلقه بشرين في هذه اللحظه ههه
بيقول اين الكرامه يا شيرين هذا الشيء همم
جدي
يعني ههه
والله انا حياتي الشخصيه وانا حره فيها لا
لم تعد حياه شخصيا اصبحت حياه مباحه للراي
العام كله ومباحه من خلالها في فرق بين
تلصص احد بيكتب اخبار عن شيرين وفي فرق
بينها هي اللي بتذيع هذه الاخبار بكل هذا
الوضوح وكل هذا العنف والتطرف في
الناحيتين سواء في الهجوم او في الدفاع
وبعدين تدخل بقى فكره المعمول لهم عمل
وحاجات كده يعني داخله داخله في قضيه كمان
يعني لا يجوز حتى انه في في الزمن ده حد
يتكلم عن سحر وسحره نعملهم حاجه يعني يعني
الامور كلها ملخبطه وليست في صالح شيرين
برغم انها واحده من اهم الاصوات على
الساحه العربيه قطعه يعني نتمنى لها كل
الخير طبعا الفنانه المحبوبه شيرين وشكرا
جزيلا لك الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي كان
معنا القاهره
[موسيقى]
نبض من الضوء والنور في الرياض خلال
نوفمبر السبب هو مهرجان نور الرياض اللي
يعتبر احتفال سنوي الضوء والفن يعزز من
خلاله الابداع ويدعم المواهب وبقدم تجارب
مذهله نور الرياض كان بدا في الثالث من
نوفمبر واستمر او مستمر لغايه 19 نوفمبر
وكنا احنا تناولنا في تفاعلكم تفاصيل
الاحتفال اللي بيتضمن 500 فعاليه
عمل فني بمشاركه من الفنانين المعاصرين من
40 دوله حول العالم ومن بينهم
34% من السعوديه وغير طبعا هل الفعاليات
والانشطه الفنيه والحوارات والتجارب
الابداعيه ورش العمل فاحتفال هاي السنه
ايضا راح ينظم مزاد فني خيري ياتي ضمن
مبادرات مشروع الرياضه
ويضم اعمال فنيه لاربعه فنانين سعوديين
تعاون مع اربعه جمعيات خيريه كل العوائد
الماليه من المزاد ستستخدم لدعم البرامج
الفنيه للجمعيات الراعيه للمزاد وكل فنان
من الاربعه سيقدم عملين فنيين تعرض في حي
جاكس طوال فتره الاحتفال الممتده للتسع
والعشرين منه بنت التاسعه عشر عفوا من
نوفمبر كما ذكرنا بالاضافه لطرحها في مزاد
افتراضي على منصه
بتاريخ 14 و15 نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
معنى من الرياض نوفل منيف مديره احتفال
نور الرياض اهلا بك يا ست نوف معنا في
تفاعلكم بدايه
اعطينا فكره عن مهرجان نور الرياضه عن
النشاطات وعن فكرته ورسالته ايضا
طبعا مرحبا فيكم وشكرا على الاستضافه طبعا
احتفال نور الرياض زي ما ذكرتي
انه هو احتفال سنوي يحتفل بفنون الضوء
طبعا احنا بدانا اوريدي من ثلاثه نوفمبر
وحيستمر يوم 19 نوفمبر تحت عنوان نحلم
بافاق جديده طبعا
زي كمان ما قلتي انه عندنا اكثر من 190
عمل فني موزعه على 40 موقع في مدينه
الرياض من اكثر من 130 فنان عملي عالمي
ومحلي من 40 دوله تقريبا همم
طبعا عندنا ال ال اكثر من من ضمن الفعاليه
عندنا اكثر من 500 من ضمن الاحتفال عندنا
اكثر من 500 فاعليه تتضمن هذه الفعاليات
ورش عمل حوارات بين الفنانين عروض موسيقيه
طبعا بعض هذه الفعاليات بتضمن تذاكر وكل
هذه التذاكر هتروح لجمعيات خيريه باذن
الله
وفي كمان مزاد على يعني همم طبعا على اربع
لوحات او عفوا على لوحات يمكن لوحتين لكل
فنان ولا لوحه واحده لاربع فنانين سعوديين
ايضا رايحه
الانشطه الخيريه اكيد حطينا اكثر عنها هذه
النقطه تحديدا
طبعا من ضمن مبادرات الرياضات اللي هو
المزاد الفني الخيري
طبعا بتعاون من اربع فنانين السعوديين
اللي هم دكتور سعد الهويدي دكتور احمد
ماطر راشد الشعشعي ومعاذ العوفي تعاونوا
مع اربع جمعيات خيريه اللي هم جمعيه
النهضه جمعيه الاراده الجمعيه السعوديه
لمرضى الزهايمر وفريق التاهيل الدولي كل
فنان عمل لوحتين بالتعاون مع هذه مع
منسوبين منسوبين الجمعيه واطفال الجمعيه
وطبعا كونوا ثمانيه اعمال فنيه انتل هذه
الاعمال همم معروفه في همم جاكس همم اللي
في الدرعيه همم طبعا وهي همم تم طرحها
لمزاد افتراضي يوم 14 و15 نوفمبر طبعا
المزاد الافتراضي اللي هو هيبدا بعد
الساعه 12:00 اليوم بالليل باذن الله
وكل هذه المبالغ حتى تروح للجمعيات
الخيريه طيب حتى الان كيف كان اقبال همم
يعني الجماهير على هذا المهرجان هلا يمكن
البعض بعض من فعالياته متخصصه نوعا ما على
الاقل يعني للناس اللي همم مهتمين بالفن
همم يعني ممكن يتابعوه ولكن الناس
العاديين هل هناك ايضا اهتمام او شو
الفعاليات اللي ممكن تكون تجذبهم اكثر من
غيرها
طبعا طبعا همم
بالمشاركه المجتمعيه اللي احنا عاملينها
همم في احتفال الرياضه 2022 اللي هو زي ما
ذكرت اليوم اكثر من 500 فعاليه وهذه
الفعاليات نفسها احنا نبغى همم يعني همم
نوصل الفن همم
يعني لكل همم
المجتمع همم في الرياض لزوار مدينه الرياض
للطلاب للطالبات همم عندنا همم يعني سكول
تويز اللي هي رحلات وجولات للمدارس
والجامعات يعني احنا همم قد ما نقدر نبغى
نحاول نوصل الفن الجميل
طيب والمراه السعوديه كان لها نصيب
الفنانه السعوديه كان لها نصيب ايضا
بالمشاعر همم فعاليات هذا همم المهرجان
حاطين عن عن المشاركه
عندنا طبعا تقريبا اكثر من 15 فنانه
سعوديه مشاركه في احتفال نور الرياض طبعا
احنا عند تقريبا
التي 39 الى 38 فنان سعودي وسعوديه ومنهم
تقريبا اكثر من 15 فنانه طبعا يعني اسامي
ما شاء الله عليهم يعني زي ما يقولون
اسامي جديده في عالم الفن وطبعا الاسامي
طبعا معروفه امم كل هذه الاعمال الفنيه
موجوده في الاحتفال اللي هو حيستمر ليله
19 نوفمبر وكمان موجوده في المعرض المصاحب
اللي هيستمر ان شاء الله لين اربعه فبروري
شكرا جزيلا لك نوفل منيف مديره احتفال نور
الرياض كانت معنا من الرياض ونتمنى لكم كل
التوفيق
واضح نراها في الافاق
[موسيقى]
تنير الطريق
تنير الحياه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما يدفعون للمضي قدما وما يجعلنا نصل كل
بعيد
[موسيقى]
هي تجمعنا
هي نور الرياض
[موسيقى]